alright we got a trailer for the new
bumblebee movie the Transformers
spin-off starring bumblebee this is my
review for it which isn't really a
review again as all trailer reviews
there's just my thoughts on I call it
review because don't hate the player
hate the game and it might look like I
just woke up it's because it's allergy
season and I did I did just wake up
faster the new bumblebee trailer when I
heard they were making a bumblebee
spin-off movie I was like I need to see
a trailer because of the Transformers
movies I mean the first one I enjoyed
when he came out I gotta live by that
didn't like all of it but it's clearly
the best one I was like I have to see it
trailer then I saw a trailer and I was
like that doesn't look bad who knew
first of all bumblebee is a Volkswagen
bug remember in the first movie he
started out as a bug and then he turned
into a Camaro because funding
sponsorship product placement got to
make ends the point is I'm very sure if
you look at the Transformers GM it's
like yeah you're gonna use art stuff but
in this movie he's the Volkswagen bug
which is what bumblebee was so right
there it takes it back including the
fact that it takes place in the 80s
which is when transformers really made
their big mark when it came out so I
love that Hailee Steinfeld I love also
if you haven't seen edge of 17 please
watch it it's great she's great in it
yeah so Hailee Steinfeld gets this car
she realizes hey it's a transformer it
transforms over her and now you have the
Iron Giant or et or stranger things or
whatever story is about someone who
finds an extraordinary friend whether it
be extraterrestrial or otherwise and the
government's after him but you know they
have that connection is it's a story
we've seen a hundred times before but
damn it if it doesn't usually work bring
on Mac and me Mac and me and bumblebee I
do like how he looks - it looks like the
Transformers in this movie I mean by the
end it's gotten crazy and the
Transformers transform all these little
nano parts shift around and when they're
standing there as robots you can't tell
what they used to be what was the
camouflage of that transformer what
automobile did they look like no idea no
one could know by looking at that but in
this movie bumblebee transformed the
hood part is his chess he's got hood
lights four nipples even Starscream it
looks like Starscream when he's flying
the nose part comes down into his chest
that's how Starscream would transform in
the old day if you showed me Starscream
from the other Transformers movies and
you were like what character is that I'd
be like I have no idea what it looks
like this Starscream will be
recognizable as Starscream I might be
saying that because I see the red and a
loose Starscream watch is not even
Starscream I don't make me my worries
won't
like this movie more or less will be
what we wanted from the Transformers
movie though it only concentrates on
bumblebee but that's awesome you don't
have a lot of human beings you don't
have a lot of transformers you have one
human being and one transformer together
so that's time you can dedicate with
them unless they bring a whole family
dynamic into it and they concentrate
more on her than bumblebee and it's it's
a balance I got to do the balance right
we've seen what it's like when
transformers concentrates on humans too
much without the Transformers people
generally don't like it so show me
bumblebee with bumblebees new friend
Hailee Steinfeld she fills that pain she
feels the sadness we feel the sadness we
want bumblebee to get away hang out in
Bernie Mac's auto shop which I like that
they did the voiceover for him to like
Bernie Mac he's finally interesting it's
perfect that he doesn't talk it's so
much better in a movie like this where
the big robot the big alien the big
extraordinary friend doesn't talk much
even Elevens like that because
connection predates words which hey when
he shoots that tape at her head Oh some
good reflexes that girl's a ninja but he
still can't talk in the first
Transformers movie and ratchets like I'm
still working on it and shooting a laser
at his neck I'm like you've been working
on that for a while
bumblebee has not been able to talk for
around 25 years he has been mute for
about a quarter of a century
whatever you're doing it's not working I
don't think you're qualified to be a
doctor on guys in the end this bumblebee
trailer I really liked it it goes for
the formula we've seen before if I
connect with this movie in a way I've
not connected with the Transformers
movies yet this movie will have done
this job whatever to the familiar
formula so the fact that the trailer
looks good the director is the director
of Kubo and the two strings Hailee
Steinfeld is the main lead human and it
revolves around bumblebee and bumblebees
we all want to love bumblebee even when
bumblebees in the Transformers movies
you hate you want to love bumblebee in
them so what can I say this movie
doesn't look bad it looks like it could
be good alright the bumblebee trailer
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]